Для європейських міністерств фінансів -
це офшорна зона:
Кариби та їхній податковий рай.
Ангілья - заморська територія Великобританії,
14 кілометрів скель, казкові пляжі,
10 тисяч жителів
та понад 10 тисяч офшорних фірм - поштових скриньок.
Для інвесторів Ангілья цікава тим, чого в ній немає:
а саме - відкритих реєстрів підприємств та податків
- ані на дохід, ані на прибуток.
Інвестори зберігають анонімність, принаймні донині.
Є легітимні причини зберігати анонімність,
це багаті, відомі люди.
Знаєте, вони відвідують острів і не хочуть,
щоб усі знали, що це їхня вілла, їхня яхта.
Йдеться про їхню приватність, це законна підстава.
Хто, наприклад, інвестував у цей готель?
Тепер цим зацікавився Євросоюз.
Якщо Ангілья не оприлюднить дані про інвесторів,
то може потрапити у чорний список
в оточенні Тринідаду, Намібії, Палау та Гуаму.
Загалом за сімома країнами з податковим раєм
нині пильно спостерігають,
інші 65 потрапили в так званий
"сірий список". На думку Стіва Гарліка,
ЄС зі своїми новими правилами зайшов занадто далеко.
Відкриття імен інвесторів може дорого коштувати острову
та вщент зруйнувати його підприємницьку модель.
Я не вважаю, що є необхідність це робити.
Але якщо Великий Брат змусить нас до цього,
тоді так, ми муситимемо це зробити.
Причина, чому ми опинилися у сірому списку, - у їхніх змінах.
Ми були в білому списку, в нас нічого не змінилося,
це вони змінили правила і ми маємо тепер дотримуватися їх.
Утім, для ЄС чорний список -
це мірило у боротьбі проти несплати податків.
Навіть якщо поки немає жодних
конкретних санкцій для чорних овечок.
Міжнародні інвестори вивчать цей список і не зможуть довгостроково
інвестувати в ці країни, які є в переліку,
тому що це, можливо, матиме для них наслідки
які можуть зруйнувати їхню бізнес-модель.
Є страх країн перед санкціями щодо інвесторів
та страх тих, хто приховує там гроші.
Чого бракує в чорному списку Євросоюзу,
то це податкових оаз у межах самого ЄС.
Монако, Люксембург,
Лондон та Гібралтар ще навіть не перевіряли.
Transparency International вимагає:
ЄС має поширити і на них свій список.
Ідеться також про країни, які тісно співпрацюють з ЄС,
партнери - такі як Швейцарія та США.
Було зрозуміло, що ці країни ніколи не потраплять у список,
хоча дослідження показали, що в них є таємні фінансові оази,
які мали би бути в списку, якби його склали об'єктивно.
Такі аргументи до вподоби острівним жителям,
вони вимагають рівноправ'я.
Я вірю в те, що до кінця 2018 року
ми виконаємо всі умови,
ми над цим активно працюємо.
І я не бачу причин, чому цього не має статися.
Ми повинні перейти із сірого списку в добрий список -
і це точно не чорний.
Відтоді, як руйнівний ураган Ірма
пронісся минулого року островом,
йому ще більш необхідно, щоб фінансова галузь
й надалі приносила прибутки для місцевих жителів.
Місце у чорному списку
стало б для Ангільї катастрофою.